[Music]
for those of you who don't work in the
pharmaceutical industry
um what this and indeed for those of you
do this diagram in front of you
is a uh essentially
an org chart and it's also a timeline so
this is how the biostatistics department
at gsk is structured
i say it's like a timeline because our
structure essentially reflects the drug
development life cycle
so this can take up to 15 years which is
what this hour at the bottom is is
presenting
um and that takes us through some of the
research in vivo in vitro
analysis all the way through to the
clinical development
and by and large if that you're not from
industry or or
you are and that's familiar to you um
you can slice this up into two
distinct ways of working really um the
first is
uh the sort of non-clinical area and
that's actually where
my group cisco data sciences sits but
it's also where research statistics on
our manufacturing
statistics groups as well and there's a
large group of statisticians programmers
data scientists around about 100 people
but overwhelmingly the vast majority of
people in our group sit within the
clinical space
and the clinical space has very very
different controls and ways of working
to the non-clinical space and it's the
clinical space
that we're going to be talking about
today so a team of
500
clinical data scientists that we're
going to call them and i put data
scientists
in quotes on this slide um because
really if you speak to anyone in that
department very few people would
actually call themselves a data
scientist
they are made up of people whose job
title is either statistician or
programmer generally
and and one of the reasons why i think
that i would also probably not call them
data scientists in a sense
is that for me a data scientist is
someone
who is multi-skilled in a number of
different ways
so they're not simply a statistician
they can code a bit as well they can use
different languages to use the right
tool for the job
and although there's a huge amount of
talent in that 500
sub-decisions for programmers at the
start of our journey
they weren't really data scientists in
in the sense that
i'm describing and just to give you an
idea of some
what kinds of skills we do have away
from just your statistics and your
programming skill
um i put up some proficiency some rough
estimates of
proficiency within the department um at
the start of this journey in 2018.
and as you can see the overwhelming
quality can program in stats i've said
99 i'd put 100 but i'm allowing myself
a little bit of room for for one or two
people who can't but essentially
everybody can program in sas
there is some proficiency in r in the
clinical space but um
largely r has been used historically for
the generation of graphics
and sas still dominates in that area
it's it's normally bespoke
difficult graphics that are particularly
difficult to generate in sas that
that r has been used for um along with a
few very proactive r users pushing alpha
graphics
and for clinical trial simulations
um where r arguably uh lends itself
uh better towards simulations
um python again i'm trying to cover
myself with one percent essentially
nobody's using python
in this clinical space um but just in
case i put one percent there
and julia essentially i've i've put up
there to make it sound like i know what
i'm talking about
um essentially no one is using that
either
so why why are we not using r well
uh a lot of it comes down to uh the past
20 or 30 years of drug development
and uh skills have been built up
over that time in sas and alongside
those skills the tools we use
um what are called sas macros which if
you're not familiar with sas
would be akin to an r function but you
can think of for all the functions and
packages you might build in our all
those kind of tools that we build to
make our job easier
are all have all been built in sas and
in a clinical
space it's very very heavily regulated
and so we have systems that control
to verify nature our workflows that we
use
and these systems as well are entirely
built for sas
carpool add all that to the fact that
it's very conservative
the further along you get along the
pipeline the more conservative it gets
um within within our industry
and you can see why our hasn't been
hasn't been used
but the real one um the the divide here
a lot is this statement here that
regulators only accept analyses perform
in sas this is essentially a myth that
has been around for a long time
um it gets repeated in various different
forms
and and i'll try to give you an idea at
the bottom of the slide as to what
really
that means and where that comes from at
least where i think it comes from um
so you have for example when you submit
filing for submission
with the fda the food and drug
administration of america
you um you have to um provide data sets
in this sas transport format
and that's an open format and this
statement is you
put a link in the bottom as to where
that comes from um but this statement
um here is from from the fda it's
clearly an open standard i put a line of
code
a bit of pseudo code on the right hand
side um to highlight just how easy that
is to generate in in our in fact there's
less code in r than it would take in sas
ironically um but they
these kinds of things these kinds of
statements get put out there and i think
because it has assassinated it's always
just something that
has to be used where people aren't very
very close to the submission end of
things
it's easy to see how that gets changed
and transformed over time and people get
very used to this
sas dominated way of working
um on the regulatory note um i could
talk for an entire hour
um i won't be but i could talk for
another entire hour
um this topic and phil mentioned that an
introduction
if you are interested in um the
regulatory barriers
um or perceived regulatory barriers that
we face in the pharmaceutical space i
would recommend you go to
www.pharmarr.org this is the
our validation hub that phil mentioned
and
you can see here in particular our white
paper on
a risk-based approach to package
validation
so given all those barriers and
challenges why are we looking at are now
um i think one of the key reasons is the
influx of new
talent and skill around our coming from
college from university
and we may have people who have been
using sas for 20 or 30 years but with
this
people with skills in our generally
they're
not coming out with skills in sas and
what we're doing is because no one else
understands our very well we're having
to retrain them
you know they've all their education has
been in our and we're retraining them in
sas
to make them uh so that they can work
with everybody else
and now i think it's probably fair to
reach critical mass so we've got so many
people who know all want to use our that
we're now looking at the other way
around let's retrain some of our
um you know some of the people that have
been there for 20 or 30 years in
in our the other piece is the drive for
innovation and that's not
new we're always driving for innovation
but i think there's a there's a few
things in particular that i've
highlighted on this slide
the last two the communication and
visualization and the
uh the productivity games i mentioned
i'll go through in a bit more detail in
the next slide
for now just to talk about the
methodologies and simulation
what we're seeing is um an increased
drive to use
the latest statistical methodologies to
try and design more efficient
trials and when i talk about more
efficient trials what i mean is
if you think about a drug getting to
market up until the point where you have
proved the efficacy and the safety of
that drug
your drug is something that you want to
expose as few people to
as as possible it's a potentially
dangerous compound that we want to make
sure that we
we're minimizing that exposure so we
need to reduce that
and equally if it's if it is effective
and it's safe we want to get it to
market as quickly as possible and
there's been a lot of investment
in things like placebo reuse of data bsk
and other other methodologies to try and
um create a more streamlined process for
developing developing drugs
and a lot of that requires heavy amounts
of simulation
um and there are a lot of tools that
have been built around that are
available in r
so they're really really pushing things
forward as well
before i move on to the last two when i
talk about visualization and
the dynamic reporting aspect i just want
to mention a couple of others that often
get
talked about in relation to adoption of
r
the first one being cost i think cost
is important in certain situations
um it wouldn't put it as a as
as important as any of the other things
on this slide actually
um when you think about cost yes r is
free and
uh tools like sas are not but there's a
huge cost in training 500 people
um and uh updating uh all of our
standard tools and and systems and so on
as well
so in a sense that the cost yes there's
some long-term cost savings but in the
short term it's actually
it's probably the other way around uh
and then the last one the gateway to
python and open source
everything i'm talking about here with
respect to r you could
switch out r and put in python or any
other open source tool
um r is um being more statistical i
guess in nature at least in its origins
compared to something like
like python um it is a more natural
language in the pharmaceutical space to
to to use um and that's why we've
chosen it as as the tool to um to sit
alongside sas
but certainly once we prove the case for
for r and if you go back to that
validation point you you can
you can prove that because for r why not
python why not
julia why not other languages once
you're in that open source space
you can start taking advantage of some
of the interoperability between these
tools okay
so the two gsk catholics i wanted to
talk about um the first one
is a shiny use case um
and uh this is something we call
quantitative decision making at gsk
um in a nutshell um it is the
probability of being able to make a
decision
at the end of the trial given um
the operating characteristics of the
study um to the study design
and various other pieces of information
that we know up front
um i don't want to talk through this in
a lot of detail again this is something
i have given a whole presentation on in
in the past um but essentially what we
try and do with quantitative decision
making at gsk is we take
uh known value so up in the top right
hand corner there's a diagram
here where it talks about this is
looking at treatment difference so on
the x-axis you've got a difference
for example a difference between our
drug and placebo or our drug and some
competitor on the market
and in a standard clinical
trial you might look at uh the
difference between those two compounds
and uh you're going to generate some
kind of p-value uh
and if it's a late phase study you might
be looking for something like p less
than 0.05 to show that there is some
kind of treatment difference and that's
great at the study level but what qdm is
looking at really is
is the life cycle of the compound so in
the early phases
of development so in phase two
where qd is particularly um used
uh gsk you you
you can't you can't power study
sufficiently to be able to make those
um uh p lesson 0.5 kinds of statements
what you want to be able to do is given
everything you know about the drug
you want to be able to estimate
probabilities what's the probability
that
the difference between our two compounds
is greater than
some clinically meaningful commercially
viable difference
okay now all of this is is quite
complicated using
uses of bayesian framework we put priors
on all the information we know
there's a lot of study design elements
that we consider and what we're trying
to get to at the end is
is the probability of success the
studies so the probability that we're
going to be able to make a clear
decision
as to whether to continue into the next
phase of development or stop
stop development of our compound
and because it's quite complicated when
we trained
a lot of our clinicians in the
methodology
they weren't immediately receptive to
everything that we were saying it's a
lot of complex mathematics
when when mathematics is generally not
not their first
uh their first job so
we developed an app and in doing so
take all of those factors things like
the sample size
the randomization ratio the standard
deviation things you can see on this
screen here hopefully
and you combine that with information
about the minimum value and the target
value
uh and potentially lots of other
operating characteristics
as well and you allow the clinicians
and the clinical teams to play around
with the sliders different options
and and then it starts to become real
for them they can start to see what the
impact of study design is on the
ultimate probability of success
and that's really led because this is
such an important initiative at gsk it's
rolled out all across all of our studies
at gsk they're in that phase of
development and
because of that we're seeing widespread
um uh adoption of um
the qdm methodology everyone is seeing
the shiny apps and there's a huge number
of requests
for additional shiny apps
second example i'll brief uh go over
this a little bit more briefly the
is dynamic reporting um essentially our
submission process
at the moment or our development process
is such that we generate
summary data sets in a very
old-fashioned
uh boring text tables
um uh format at the moment
and we generate these in the same way
we've done for 20 or 30 years
and that's fine for our submissions but
then when
when we want to present those in a
powerpoint presentation or we want to
publish those
results in some other way what we find
ourselves doing is reformatting all that
information
even in fact in the clinical study
report we handle we hand over the data
to our medical writing teams and they
end up doing things like manually
merging columns and
uh reformatting some of the data that
we've given them before it goes to the
clinical study report
so you could use if you had um
if you weren't using microsoft products
something like our markdown would be
equally uh
suitable for this we actually used the
officer package to prove this concept
last year that we could just take the to
take the
data sets the summary data sets that we
generate in biostatistics
and automatically place all of the
outputs into
each of these different formats without
the need
for huge amounts of transcription qc
which is what takes place today
so if there's give me a bit of an
introduction and a couple of cathodes a
couple of things that we're looking at
that are really
accelerating the um the adoption of r
within gsk
what i want to move on to now is
generally how we're trying to build
this capability so we've that's i guess
some of the marketing company
advertising that we've done internally
to promote our
and in building capability i've put up
something here which will probably
horrify
um anyone working in change management
but what i'm calling a simple recipe for
building capability because
the the components here the ingredients
if you like in the stress
video are not rocket science it's more
about how how you do it and that's what
we'll talk about in the rest of this
webinar so tilo's going to talk about
the environment that we've
built about warp environment and michael
will talk about our
um the way that we're promoting
on-the-job learning through an
initiative called alpha qc
um before i move on to training i just
want to highlight as well that given
this is a heavily regulated industry
um processes and standards also plays a
big part we actually have standard
operating procedures that effectively
reference sas directly not intentionally
but
our workflows are so built around the
sas workflow um that certain
elements that don't even make sense uh
for r
uh and of course marketing that i've
mentioned
so let's let's move on look at training
before i hand over to to tea later talk
talk you through the warp environment
what you can see on the slide now which
is a build
slide is uh three prongs of how we
talk about data science within
biostatistics and this is largely based
around our traditional roles
so at the top we talk about modeling and
modelling is the role that's
traditionally performed by statistician
in gsk biostatistics and a
a programmer would fulfill a
wrangling role within biocystics the
role that
my team fulfills um in promoting
r is more of an engineering role and
engineering can be lots of different
things for lots of different people what
we mean in this space is
things like building the environments
building applications building our
packages
so if you like the tooling that goes
that helps support data science
analyses and the way we've gone about
training everybody
is to focus on the tidy verse and focus
on gg plot two so i've
written these two things ggplot2 is
clearly part of the tidyburst the reason
i've separated them out in this diagram
is because they are two separate
face-to-face courses that we
we created which are now virtual courses
um for everyone in biostatistics we want
to make sure everyone's got to a base
level in television before we move on
we chose tidy verse because um of all of
the reasons you would normally choose
tidy burst
so things like the simplicity of the
functions the consistency and so on
but also because if you're trying to
take people who know sas and train them
in
r r is a lot more expansive than sas as
a language you have things like matrices
and lists and so on
uh and can get quite complicated um when
you get
when you get into it sas on the other
hand is built around very simple flows
of
built around data steps something called
data steps in sas
and the way that that works is is very
very similar to the way that
the tidy verse is built around data
frames or
tibbles in the tidy verse vernacular
so that makes it a lot easier for
someone coming across from sas that are
to pick up tibbles and pick up that way
of working than it does
and in particular you know the magrita
pipe and everything everything like that
is
very familiar to people coming from a
sas background
so build them up in the foundations and
then in each of the core areas we
um we then look to strengthen core
competencies so
we have bespoke training in various
different forms
um i put in the right-hand side some of
the methods of delivery so this
this will not all be face-to-face
training lots of this is guidebooks
webinars all sorts of different things
that we that we do to promote
the learning um and they'll be called
stats training um
using real gsk data in programming prog
plus here represents sort of more
targeted training in things like
stringer
lubridate those kind of packages for
more advanced data manipulation and then
we look at things like function writing
from an engineering perspective
and then when the value comes in it's
around these kinds of things so
shiny clearly plays a big part uh
of our future so we've got some
expansive um
targets around building shiny capability
publishing here i'm using to refer to
things like um
officer as well as our markdown book
down block down those kinds of tools as
well
you can see that through this we're
building
capabilities in each direction across
the group
okay in this particular section what i'm
going to focus on is the environment
that we've built
to support statisticians programmers and
data scientists within biostatistics and
increasingly now beyond biostatistics as
well
we call this environment warp because
it's part of a wider initiative called
space and if you want to make that
into an acronym
we sometimes talk about the working area
for
our programming
okay so
as has been mentioned in the
introduction
the majority of our users
are clinical users statisticians and
programmers and
the kind of data they work with clinical
trial data
is relatively small in in the data
science space
so a few hundred subjects
visiting a clinic a handful of times
maybe less than 10 times
generating at most in some of our
laboratory data sets a few megabytes of
data
um certainly not generally in the
gigabyte terms
and the kind of analyses that we we're
running are
standard statistical models linear
models generalized linear models mixed
models cox proportional hazards these
kinds of things
and when we simulate that data
what we have is computationally
demanding simulations where we fit that
model over and over again
as opposed to uh needing to work with
very very large data sources and trying
to solve
problems with memory and so on um the
only exception to that is that we are
seeing increasing use
of molecular molecular and genomics data
as well
and that's something that we'll have to
adapt to and respond to in the future
so in terms of what that means our
environment needs to cover well we need
an interactive environment its core and
i'll talk through each of these
components in the next few slides
separately
we need a high performance capability
to support those simulations as i
mentioned and
with respect to our new capabilities our
shiny apps and our markdown
based workflows we need an ability to
share
that kind of content okay
and of course to do anything we need
access to all of our data sources
um we've provided this through a
centralized environment that
probably isn't a surprise to anyone who
works in this industry um but our aim is
to get people
um off desktops where we can and provide
a level of consistency particularly in
the clinical setting
we need consistency traceability and
transparency and what
and what we do and we have a large
number of users that we need to support
when doing this so
um around we have capacity at the moment
for around about a thousand
data scientists with three with 300
concurrent users we estimate
this diagram is just to highlight some
of the technologies that are included
in this environment you'll see as well
as r you'll see technologies like python
and stan
mentioned generally we access those
through our
as opposed to direct access through
their own
ides so everything is built around our
studio server pro
and it's very much designed as an r
based
environment okay um
all of those other components there are
really just
supporting supporting the the the use of
our so
even take something like git and github
um
that's actually maintained completely
separately but we'll provide a
connection
in our to allow um the our code to be
stored and managed through
um through github
so we've chosen our studio server pro
and again maybe this is an obvious
choice for many people
but um clearly the rstudio ide is the
standard ide for var anyway
um but it increasingly in the data
science space i do see
um a sort of a trends towards
more notebook like environments but
really in a clinical space that doesn't
work we work with we work with scripts
primarily and for those users coming
across from coming across from sas
all they've ever known really is scripts
so first and foremost we need an
environment to be able to
develop and execute scripts
and our studio server pro is
is really nice in that it provides well
our studio
vr studio ide generally provides
notebook access and
obviously easy use of our markdown if
you want it
um and therefore is the best of both but
it also provides
the ability to uh load balance so for us
with our high number of users
we actually have two servers with our
studio server pro running
and we users will log on to a single
single address and they'll be put onto
whichever server has the most
capacity and this is also really really
useful for things like maintenance
to minimize the downtime that users
experience as well
um there are some challenges with the
interactive environment the load
balancing with respect to high
performance usage but
i'll come on to that after the the next
slide
so in this slide what i want to talk
about is our
means to manage such an environment so
for a regulatory environment i suppose
at the moment we are quite
uh open so we're not locking much down
for our users
um first and foremost we need to get
people off laptops with with our and on
a laptop they're used to
high levels of flexibility so we provide
a central
um installation of r and that
installation
um is updated every six months
so we have many many versions of our and
um all of the
recent versions are exposed to users so
um
for every six months over a period of
three years you can go back and select a
version of our
that you want to use and when we talk
about a version of r we don't just mean
the core and recommended packages
to to date we currently have around 450
packages centrally installed in a system
library as well so when a new user
logs onto the system they get
access to um tidy verse
and and other popular packages for our
uh
our kind of work immediately and they
don't have to go and install those
packages and
moreover because these are the central
installed in the system library
everyone has the same version of those
packages which ensures a degree of
stability
and usage um we do allow flexibility so
users can install their own packages as
well in their own
personal user library um we're not
restricting that at the moment
but it's very likely that we'll
supplement this environment in the
future with more static
um stable versions of um
[Music]
of r that are a bit more locked down and
the only element of control that we
really have
on the environment is provided through
our studio package manager
so our studio package manager um
provides uh access to packages that
the users would typically go and install
from crayon bioconductor github and so
on
um and and with respect to crown and
bioconduct we pretty much provide the
whole of crown and
we do provide the whole of crown and
bioconductor for github users would have
to request
that particular repositories are um
added to our environment before they can
install that so they can't directly
access cran
bioconductor or github or anywhere else
and we also have
our own github enterprise at gsk as well
which we
um we release packages onto and users
users can use our studio package manager
manager to access those what's actually
really really nice about
our studio package manager is that it
allows us to monitor the downloads
and so when we see users installing many
users installing the same package
um what we can what we can then do is to
install that in the central system
library in a future release
again just to limit the amount of
personalization and customization that
might affect
the transferability of our code
and speaking of central monitoring
another really nice feature that
is that our admin support team use
quite extensively is the admin
screens that are available um through
our studio um through our studio server
pro
so here you can see a view of our system
um
what i haven't mentioned thus far is
that the system um
these two servers that we use are very
very powerful servers originally
attended for high performance computing
so they each have 192 cores and three
terabytes of ram
which is why you can see sort of one
percent cpu memory usage
on here um so generally we are not
pushing these servers to their to their
limits
what you can can see those these little
spikes that occur here
and these uh these spikes occur when a
user tries to paralyze
um or does successfully paralyze code
and executes that
um in in the background um
so we can monitor the system see these
spikes and then talk to those users
um users are permitted to to
generate you know they are allowed to
paralyze code and they are allowed to
practice hbc's runs but our expectation
is that they run them on a separate
um hpc uh system which i'll talk through
next
so that system is fully accessible from
our studio server pro environment um so
we
built a an add-in to access
slurm which is the tool that we use the
for
accessing hpc so you can see on here
each one of these is a different
server so when the users in our studio
server pro access that add-in
that the information they enter there
essentially writes the necessary script
to launch uh that job
on to two separate hpc
nodes again all of these nodes um every
single one of these servers in this
diagram has
has 190 and three terabytes of memory
which is
far too much for our management node
doesn't need anything like that
um uh i'm no doubt we'll change that in
the future but
um certainly for the hbc that means
we've got some very powerful servers
available
one point no i mentioned that we've
built a an add-in for this
we were sort of bleeding edge when we
were
when we were doing this and the
functionality wasn't readily available
in our studio um i understand that it is
available
now you can use launcher within our
studio to work with slurm as well as
kubernetes um but until gsk up
migrates to to start using kubernetes
um we are still using our own custom
add-in at this moment in time
so beyond the obvious i just want to now
highlight
the value add i guess of this
environment so the new things that we
can do now that we we couldn't already
do in our sas based environments
and for content sharing so for sharing
shiny apps our markdown documents
book down block down we
use our studio connect
we have one server at the moment running
our studio connect
in future again that might be too so we
might evolve to have a
development and production server but at
the moment it's all in one and it's a
pretty liberal model so users can
publish anything they
they like and so you see a lot of apps
development apps with the word test next
to them um
primarily i'd say the shiny apps are i
mean the showing apps are a mixed bag we
get all sorts the qdm
quantitative decision making app that i
mentioned earlier
we get various dashboards that people
people have created
um training apps and so on um the image
in the left hand side is taken from a
proof of concept we did to use shiny to
report clinical trial
data so we've got an ongoing initiative
at the moment where we're looking at uh
replacing a lot of our standard outputs
with with a shiny app and there's a lot
of questions that come with that
around things like uh data access and
um and what to do what to do if we find
anything
in there when we're exploring the data
how do we report that and so on
and so a lot of questions that but we're
starting to explore chinese for that as
well
otherwise we also use our studio
connects for all of our
training materials so most of those are
produced using book down and we host
those on on connect
one particular feature i want to
highlight that isn't mentioned on this
slide but this is something that i
really
i'm really really thrilled about is um
there's a feature in our studio connect
that allows you to publish directly from
git so we use git and github extensively
particularly within my team
and you can point our studio connect
directly at a particular branch on
github
so for example we'd have our production
apps
pointing at the master branch and we'll
have
a test branch where we we would
point our studio connect at um for more
regular updates
um and testing
and that's a really really nice feature
that often doesn't get talked about
that i just wanted to highlight
otherwise
i think our studio connects generally
works really really well for us
and the only bit of guidance that we we
often need to work with our users on is
around
data access so sometimes people don't
understand how our studio connect runs
you can basically configure it to run
as you as the user that's trying to
access that content
or you can configure it to run as a
generic user
and that affects things like data access
and so we're often having to work with
users to explain
um explain that equally you can
configure you can design an app so
such the data is deployed as part of the
app or you can write apps to access
external data sources where
some of what i just mentioned um becomes
becomes more of an issue
but there's lots of different mechanisms
for controlling um
controlling access within connect and
that's that's one of the key advantages
i think that we
we see over it for uh we see for it for
shiny apps is making sure that the right
people see the right content
so just before i round off i just wanted
to mention some of the the back ends
i've mentioned things like uh
relational databases um id
these are ideal for um for clinical
trial data our clinical trial data is
actually stored on file shares at the
moment
but our future in future either live on
a relational database or a graph
database
so we've provided access to a number of
internal file shares
and we're able to access relational
databases as well
and at the bottom of the slide is
mentioned hadoop clusters
outside of our sort of clinical setting
there are a number of users who want to
access things like real world data
electronic
health record databases that are stored
on
separate hadoop clusters within gsk so
we provide access to those
and then the second one down on the
slide um the object store that we have
again something that's perhaps not
talked about too much
um these days but
i think we will see it a little bit more
in the future is
um is the the concept of an object store
for the data and we we have some fairly
large
um structured and unstructured data
sources that we access through the
object store in it
it's something that's helped us develop
our first
clinical rna sequencing pipeline
um which we will be able to announce
later this year
as well as provided as well as providing
a means to
enable another pipeline that allowed us
to
analyze covert 19 data
and respond to a demand for our clinical
operations uh
group to to try and understand what the
effect
impact of kobe 19 is going to be on
clinical trial recruitment
so there's been a couple of really nice
use cases um where connected to object
store has been
particularly powerful and we're very
grateful for and the work that's gone
into getting aws s3 back onto cram
so i'll just finish with an overview of
the whole system um
i've spoken about each of these
components the only one really to
highlight that i haven't mentioned
before is this management uh in any i
haven't mentioned in any detail is this
management node
so this contains our centralized r
distribution so
whether it's connect whether it's uh
interactive environments or hpc knows
all of these are working off the bait
the same base um
our installation which sits on there um
as well as things like our studio
package manager then to manage that and
the slum workload manager so having this
extra node independent from the rest
is kind of useful it's not uh necessary
as such to have it as a separate node
and as i mentioned in the previous slide
it's a little bit overpowered at the
moment
um for what we need it for um but is a
really really useful component as well
as the load balancing that takes place
everywhere else and as mentioned a
future improvement will be to
balance the the content across the
connect servers as well
so with that i will round off and hand
over to
michael to talk about um
on the job learning so uh an initiative
um called after qc in particular thank
you very much
yeah my name is michael rimler i am in
in clinical programming within gsk
biostatistics and
i am here to talk about
our adoption story or our adoption story
uh within
clinical programming and and really in
the clinical reporting
process the objectives of this project
really are kind of twofold at a top
level um
one is driving capability so as andy
mentioned we have
um you know a vast majority of our staff
are historically sas programmers but
we're moving into this space where we
want to integrate r into the clinical
reporting process
and to do that we need that capability
we need people to be able to program in
our
and although people have you know
developed their skills
over their sas skills over time you know
i've been in the industry for
10 11 years now and virtually everything
that i've that i've learned in terms of
sas has been
on the job where i had a challenge that
i needed to figure out how to
resolve and i asked questions i looked
things up and i figured out it wasn't
from sitting
in classes and taking courses and
working on
on on problem sets and things like that
and so we want to be able to
we want to be able to build that
capability and secondly we want to
establish an environment and by
environment i don't mean what tilo's
saying
an environment although that of course
is very very important
but really um making sure that people
have the
the the right to the permission to
engage in certain activities in the
clinical reporting
process um and they we know what the
ways of working are
things like that so that someone comes
in um and then has the tools available
to them to do that as well so someone
comes in um
and and we hire them in and and apples
to apples they look the same as the
newly hired sas programmer but they
happen to know
r as andy mentioned that that this is
where a lot of the
other folks coming out of um university
are coming in with that they can be just
as productive they don't have to go
through
additional steps of learning additional
training so that they can
can be productive they can be productive
right out of the gate
along this process we've been asking
questions like why are we doing this
what's the role of r versus sas and our
future
and to andy's point that that also
brings into into account
more open source but but here we're
focusing on our so what is the role of r
versus sas
now my perspective in sort of leading
this project can and
i have the i feel like i have the
support of our our senior management is
that
it's it's integrating r and sas it's not
about flipping a switch and doing r or
sas it's about how do we integrate this
in
uh into our processes how are we doing
this what are the elements that are
needed to declare our teams to be
already and and what's next so you know
sas has
a certain amount of capabilities other
languages have certain uh
things that they excel at but the fact
that we're trying to integrate r into
our process does that
open up the door for our department to
be
delivering other things to our quote
unquote customers
beyond our conventional data sets tables
listings and figures
this started with a with a project that
that was called r for qc where we
wanted to to look at um using
r for the qc process so for those that
are
unfamiliar with a somewhat conventional
qc process
within um clinical reporting you you
have a production side programmer who
creates the output they create the data
set they create the table that sort of
thing
and then someone else an independent
programmer independently creates code
using the same inputs but then a
different process because independently
generated
and if they get the same outcome at the
end then that satisfies a significant
level of the requirements from a
validation perspective
and so that's what we were looking at
when the rfqc project
in parts one and two we focused on
displays
just looking at not not looking at data
sets
and it was more of a proof of
feasibility proof of concept type model
we only did about nine displays in uh in
in part one and then we expanded the
team and expanded and
actually in part two we we were able to
replicate or um uh
doubly uh
uh validate and compare to the
production side sash generated displays
uh using r as as opposed to sas there's
about 150 some displays that were in
that in that proof of concept
that opened the door for our part three
where where we sort of go live which was
one of our initial objectives which is
how do we open the door
for all of our staff to be able to use
our as opposed to sas for
something because that allows them to
take any training that that andy's group
is providing
and use it on the job so that they they
can immediately go out and do
their normal everyday work but start to
do it in the language of r as opposed in
the language of status
uh and so we had a number of components
which i'll go through that that
in order to get uh endorsement for being
able to do that
but we are now our part three has now
been ongoing
for about four or five months now and
and we continue to bring more and more
people in into the fold
at the same time or roughly around the
same time we launched into part four
which is a
proof of concept that moves us into the
data sets
and atom data set mapping these two
projects now have become under the
umbrella of a
sort of new and broader initiative
within within clinical programming on
our adoption
and there we you know i was sort of
tasked with you know what's the roadmap
to our then look like for clinical
programming what is it
what do we need to do to get to the
point where we are using r as much as we
are sas or at least they're sort of
interchangeable or we have a strategic
direction that sort of thing
and before i could figure out a road map
which which is when are you going to do
things i need to know what we're going
to do
what are the thing what are the
components of broad adoption of r within
the department and
that that created these sort of six or
seven work streams
which included the r for qc uh remaining
elements of parts three and part four
but looked at things like like central
tools so in
in the sas world in the sas workflow we
have
then many organizations do right we have
our sas macro
library suite that people use um we
don't have the same thing in our there's
packages out there
those packages are not written for the
clinical data pipeline
but they are they do have functionality
so what can we do
to make the uh the
the ability for uptake of our sas
programmers moving into r
easier because we're not asking them to
program for first principles
we give them a set of tools that allows
them to do that and annie's group
on that engineering side that he was
talking about and his group provided
those
initial packages that we've been using
through the rpqc project
there's also a work stream on of course
training and support for our staff
it's a massive organization and this is
a big change in terms of the way we do
our work so there's a change management
and communications piece to this
there's outreach that's outreach with
we're we're really driving this within
the clinical program department but
there's outreach
outside of clinical programming still
within biostats
and still within gsk but also external
outreach
for example this type of uh of platform
where we're
sharing our knowledge and our experience
we're not the first ones to go through
this
but we are carving our own path and and
we do have different experiences and the
more that we share
the more that we can pull the rest of
the industry along with us along with
the folks like um uh jenna and tech and
and roche
and the likes of that and then of course
we always
are thinking about well we're doing this
on the qc set of things
what does it mean to get r on to
production some of that falls within
andy's annie's group someone that falls
within the tech group and some of that
falls within
the work that we're doing and and and
there's always the the question out
there about about
submission with our generated uh
analyses and data
so that r for qc project um i talked
about a little bit already
um and andy's also mentioned some of
this also but why did we decide to
to to to use r in the r for qc project
we have this um uh this long-term
objective within clinical programming to
become programmatically multilingual
it's not driven by by sas license cost
andy already mentioned the idea of
recruitment i also think that flips to
retention for the folks that are
that have been within our group for a
long time
this offers new and exciting things they
can do if you have
interest in doing that but operationally
it also gives us flexibility the ability
to choose the right tool for the job at
hand
and also an expansion of the things that
we might deliver to our
to to our internal customers
why did we look at qc it's it's a lower
risk of entry point that's what we
thought from the beginning that
that qc programming tends to have lower
regulatory scrutiny it's not typically
submitted along with a submission
package
so therefore you can have it you can
have qc code developed
um during the the the reporting workflow
and and in r as opposed to sas and it's
not going to be challenged as much
and we're still producing everything
using sas at the moment
so we're we're taking things that are
produced in a in a
language and in a workflow that has been
commonly accepted
and we're simply using our validation
processes using
using our and and as mentioned it's
going to facilitate the sort of
on-the-job organic upscaling because we
know
that if i need to to to
validate a summary of demographics i can
go and i can use
r within our r studio environment and
and do that work
there as opposed to launching up sas
those first few parts parts one and two
on displays and now moving into part
four all proof of concepts
we're really thinking about
demonstrating the capability of
using r for stage 2 qc that's in gsk
it's referred to as independent
validation and
stage 2 qc and and and back to that
facilitating the on-the-job use of r
uh for upskilling we had a number of
successes
um with that so we have um we we had to
figure out how to actually compare data
frames we we can use proc compare and
sas
how do you do that in r uh there's a
couple of packages that that
we identified that that could satisfy
this and we landed on the
df package uh and that has been proven
successful through our experience so far
to leverage that package
um we have successful cross-functional
collaborations
most most specifically with with andy's
group
but that was needed because we didn't
have the sort of internal
um skill set that we needed in in
knowledge uh so we needed to work
cross-functionally
uh i mentioned the central tools it also
gave us a better
vision of our road map towards r and we
developed a significant amount of
supporting documentation to help our
staff
challenges that we face and i would
argue matt one is on board
into the what i would call the our
ecosystem so that's the warp environment
that's working with git and github
that's thinking about
having to as a programmer having to
worry about loading packages and
installing packages
and and things like that it's just
different than sas and so how do you
take
folks that have been using sas for 3 5
10
15 20 years and say well now we want you
to do this in r
how do you help lower the entry cost for
that so that
uptake can be higher adoption can be
stronger
proc compare and df df seems to be have
developed in design
to be very similar to proc compare but
it has a different look it has a
different feel and so we had to work
through those challenges
of how you use it as a diagnostic tool
not just
everything compare sort of uh result
good program practice on our is
different
also trying to institute some sort of
code review culture which is
i don't know what it's like in in in
every organization but it's
it's not as strong as as we would like
within gsk i think
within clinical reporting i think that's
primarily driven by the independence of
qc
uh culture but trying to to build up a
code review
mentality and good program practice
and we also notice because we're
comparing sas to our results we also
notice that there are differences
between sas and r and some fundamental
things
not that either is right or wrong when
you when we notice the differences in
the compare output and we dug into it we
realized that sas was doing what sas
said they should be doing and r was
doing what our said they should be doing
and so how do we reconcile that from a
reporting standpoint from an analysis
standpoint
if if our general concept is well things
should match exactly
and we're not getting things matching
exactly how do we sift through that more
importantly how do we support our teams
in navigating that
when you open the door to let loose 250
programmers
350 programmers to do this they need to
know all right i now see this difference
what do i do about this difference and
so we we
we started working through those sorts
of things with the sas versus our
differences that we were
encountering that brought us to part
three part three
uh is where we go to live stage two or
independent qc using our instead of sas
you you could think of run it as like a
pilot study
uh where you have a a a study that says
we're gonna just
validate everything using r instead of
that model
we chose to have uh an organic sort of
um
grassroots effort uh to doing this so
any individual programmer at the output
level can say all right i've been
assigned 25 different displays
so i'm going to choose these three and
i'm going to validate these using r
instead of stats that's the opportunity
to use
to to on the job learn r and take what
you've learned from the training coming
out of andy's group
and use it for the work that you
typically do um
part of the requirements of that we're
making sure that of course the the
the leadership on the study was aware of
what was happening because it it doesn't
put us we don't think it puts a
significant amount of risk but it's
something from a resourcing and
timelines perspective
leadership needs to know about we have
mechanisms in place to help with ways of
working and also provide visibility
on what's happening but really it's it
was putting in place
a model of encouragement from above so
we had leadership in the team saying
you can do this we allow you to do this
we know it's going to take you a little
bit longer than
then you might be able to do it in sas
because you're so fluent in sas and just
learning r
but we're going to provide all this
support from below in terms of
documentation and the support team to
answer your questions
and things like that on the right here
i'm not going to go through them it's
just we
we outlined number of required
components before we would say
it's a green light people can go out and
do this
uh and and use r it is a regulated
environment so we have to be
conservative in this approach
while we as well as the rest of the
industry is navigating
towards the ultimate objective of sort
of freely
being able to submit packages produced
and
using our and perhaps other open source
languages
some of the support magazines we have in
place i'll run through this quickly
because i know that we're running a
little bit short on time
we put together a quick start guide to
just be a one-stop shop that
uh links out to a number of internal
documentation
um and we put together on on the on the
left here is a guidance document
um that's that's pretty thorough it it
goes through
not just how to get started but also
what does it mean to develop code in r
studio how do you execute code
some mini vignettes of going through
some of our standard display templates
um standard summary of ae template
that's very gsk specific
but it gives people sample code gives
things
that they can copy and paste and swipe
slightly tweak when i was learning
sas along the way i i learned by someone
pointing me to
a a similar type output in a different
study and i would copy that code in
and i would start to manipulate it to
make sure that it worked for for my
purposes
and so i wasn't starting from a blank
sheet of paper every time i started code
so that's we wanted to do this this
document on the left which is
using the the book down package um was
it was completely
um designed to try and again lower that
transition cost of someone moving from
sas into r
in order to improve uptake and improve
adoption
on the right here is is a workplace page
with jsk uses workplace it's a workplace
page that we created
also to support staff and asking
questions and communicating out and that
sort of thing
so one of the interesting
characteristics of this is as we
released this documentation
we also got some notice
that there's more that r can do than
just our
statistical analysis type work that you
can publish
to these this sort of documentation to
rs connect our studio connect
and and that can that's just another
reason uh to integrate r
into the workflows that we have so we
move into the our adoption journey
um motivations behind this uh
to have this expanded tool set to expand
our delivery capabilities upskilling
things that we've sort of already talked
about
but we do want to become amongst those
industry leaders and not be a follower
that's where
i think andy's group wants to position
ourselves that's where we want to
position ourselves as well that's why we
have this sort of outreach stream
uh that sort of thing coming out of that
project
deliverables we want already study teams
for our conventional delivery
we want our package development team for
to enhance our prospect for process
improvement
we want to have shiny development teams
for future delivery products
and of course to have a robust support
strategy and we again we always have
this eye on on how do we get to our
first submission
so going back to the the sort of six or
seven work streams here in the r
adoption project
the the real question we have is how do
you manage change within a massive
organization
without disrupting that delivery
capability and in order to do that
we need to have a multi-faceted approach
that's where these work streams came
from
to have focused efforts within the work
stream we have leads in place for each
of these work streams
that both define the objectives and the
strategy towards delivering to those
objectives
but those things those efforts are also
integrated and coordinated because this
team works together
and the people that are on each
individual team and leading those teams
are trying to
to coordinate um and and and
with the ultimate objective of of of
serving the our adoption
uh objectives
so in the last minute and a half or two
minutes i just want to do a little bit
of a deep dive into
the essential tools that that some of
the packages that andy's team has
has created for to serve our teams in
the clinical reporting process
so we have two our studio add-ins first
we have a gsk header add-in and jsk log
add-in
the gsk header just inserts through our
studio it's an interactive way of
inserting and
updating the header in our r programs
jsk log generates an execution session
log
there's another add-in which is the
fourth bullet called copy4qc
this is an add-in that was generated we
since we're developing in the warp
environment but we need the
code the qc code to be in our study area
so it can be archived with the study
we have to be able to get it from from
one system to the other
while maintaining last modified dates
while maintaining the appropriate
permissions for the systems that they
live in
but we also need 350 programmers to be
able to do this in a very consistent
uh manner and so the best way to do that
is to provide them a tool
uh where they hit buttons and they have
less and less control uh
limited control over over how that's
happened so we can control that process
and then we have two building blocks
of actually doing the work so gsk table
building blocks of basic summary
displays and gsk data set building
blocks of
data set transformations i want to focus
a little bit on the jsk log and that'll
that'll close
me out because this is something that we
realized early on was a unique thing
here
because sas naturally generates an
execution log r
does not do that sas hits an error it
keeps going
r hits an error it stops but people are
used to seeing logs
and there's a usefulness of having some
sort of execution log because it
generates
a record of information that's related
to that execution
so it gets us towards that sort of gxp
compliance
requirements that we have the rationale
again r doesn't naturally generate this
information
so we want to be able to provide minimum
information to demonstrate the integrity
of that execution
and details to facilitate reproduction
so that if two years from now someone
were to go back and look at the program
and want to show reproducibility
they could recover what the r
environment looked like at the time
and should be able to reproduce it maybe
not with the click of a button but with
a little bit of effort you'd have the
information to reset that environment
and this is a challenge or a problem
that's specific to the clinical
reporting workflow
what was what andy's group came up with
that we helped advise on was
was not intended to replicate that sas
log
the design was as an r studio add-in we
have elements of who what and when so
who ran the file what was the file
when did it start when did it stop
uh we wanted to drop in any sort of
errors and warnings
so in this case here's a warning that
the df
doesn't have all values compared equal
so you can see
see that information about the r session
and information about the packages and
versions available we took the path of
least resistance so it's really all the
packages that are installed
in that rstudio instance
not just the packages that were used for
the production of that program
but we do have a sort of mini backlog
of enhancements that we want to want to
make to this um
to this package including moving it away
from
being an add-in and and more of a batch
execution type
implementation
you